i'm wesley lowry uh journalist with cbs
news and gq magazine uh and i'm here to
talk with the cast and the production
team behind that powerful scene from
what was one of the most powerful films
we saw this year king richard i'm joined
now uh by will smith anjanu ellis as
well as production designer wayne thomas
composer chris bowers and editor pamela
martin in addition to director ronaldo
marcus green i'm really excited for this
conversation with such a talented panel
of people um who helped show us that
powerful film from from a very important
set of lives
no ma'am
what's going on everybody okay they got
a call
said there was trouble in the house and
that we were being rough with the girls
and they needed to look
a call from who not at liberty to say
okay yeah okay
you uh you all need to look around
great you can check on in the cupboards
maybe you can go check under the beds
make sure it's no monsters it's a little
wet for practice don't you think don't
the girls have schoolwork to do they do
their homework
tundy's first in her class lynn and esha
are too
that's right girls
spell civilization
c-i-v-i-l-i-z-a-t-i-o-n
okay mr williams no it's really not
necessary hold on
you want to check on the kids let's
check on the kids
i wanted to start i actually wanted to
go to you first ray i wanted to ask you
about
how
this scene fits into the story that that
king richard tells
look i think the williams family um
you know faced a lot of adversity um by
virtue of where they lived uh
how they were raised where they grew up
and this
you know this scene sort of
highlights how just how much even no
matter how hard you're working two
parents a mom that's working full-time
dad going to the court all the things
that we're facing in their life and they
still have
to come home to someone else peering
into their house
so i i think all of that going into this
scene is so important because you've
seen we've already set up we've set up
the world in which they live in and
which they're which
you know we we're we're we're taking our
characters through this space and now
this is sort of icing on the cake how
how low can it possibly get this is as
as high as it gets when it when it comes
to
you know uh to that kind of drama
now will what do we need to know about
richard williams to understand him in
this moment and also some of the work
you did to get into his head to figure
out how he operated and and what he
would have been thinking um that
propelled this performance in this
moment
richard williams is is very very similar
to my father you know that
that uh post world war ii
uh black man with a dream coming out of
the south and and coming to the north
specifically
for a different kind of
experience you know so in in terms of
you know
being devoted and dedicated to your
children and continually finding
uh obstacles to being the kind of father
that you want to be i personally had an
experience uh you know jada and i were
reported uh for
someone said that we we weren't feeding
willow
so
we came home and the sheriffs
were
you know going through stuff they want
to interview the kids and all of that so
i unders like that that fury there's an
an insult to your manhood
when men walk in your house with guns to
check on how you treating your kids you
know so it's a it was a it was a very
emotional scene for me it's like you
know the first couple takes i couldn't i
couldn't stop crying i had to settle
myself i had to settle myself down a
little bit
you know but it's uh it's one of my my
favorite scenes in the in the whole
movie we got future doctors
and lawyers plus a couple tennis stars
in this house
now i understand you got to do your job
even if some crazy ass neighbor do call
talking foolishness
and i didn't mind you saying we hard on
these kids you know why cuz we are
that's our job to keep them off these
streets
you want to arrest us for that
fine but what you're not gonna never do
is come knock on this door talking about
you had to blow their damn brains out in
them streets cause they running with
hoodlums and doing drugs and things
that's what you're not never going to
say in this house
you want to rest us for that
that's fine you need to be arresting
them parents at them tennis matches
that's who need to be getting arrested
in this film even as it's titled king
richard about richard williams really is
a film and a story about
the partnership between two parents
we see the role forcing plays in their
life as a protector as a parent could
you talk a little bit about that
relationship and how you reported it out
as you prepared to play it and portray
it i remember that night you know so
specifically i remember though i
remember the air i remember how cold it
was i shot the exterior first and then
it was much later
if i'm remembering this correctly it was
much later that we shot that we shot the
uh the interior scene with the act with
this with the with the social worker and
the and the detectives
and what i loved about both times was
just that there was no there was no back
and forth between will and myself it was
a little something animal about it like
a bit of a bit of hive mind that kind of
you know that that took over and i i i
kind of felt that way in many instances
of working you know with
you know those moments of or scene and
richard when we had to come in defense
of our children
and how do you in the storytelling here
how do you figure out the balance of
things you're gonna have to do to make
it work storytelling wise versus how
letter and verse well actually literally
on this day venus said this and then
serena does
how do you how do you in some ways
dramatize and fictionalize a true story
isha price the venus and serena's sister
was on set every single day
so we we started with what actually
happened and we we didn't we didn't find
ourselves you know having to
uh fictionalize much in in this scene
you know we were we were
lucky and and blessed to to have the
family that was walking us through
uh
scene by scene uh to to maintain the
authenticity
richard is is the one interacting
but then there's a moment where she
walks out and she walks across the
street and you talk about her as a
mother in that moment
and what you're portraying as you have
that conversation with another mother
yeah i think you hit it it was a mother
to mother conversation which is very
different from a father to mother
conversation because there is this ocean
that we both traverse and swim
this you know in very similar ways as
opposed to a man and a woman i think
that that that silence
but there's also that that clear and
clarity of intention
um that was there and i just think that
that's their dance i think that's the
that's the richard and or scene dance
hey where you going i'll be back
hey betty you're seen
i've never been over here before
you have it that's a shame it is
will can you talk about the importance
of that partnership between
uh the parents and also
about the conversations you all had with
members of the family a clear
indication of the the power of ms
oracine and sitting and talking
uh with her she doesn't say a lot she
she is she's quiet 90 of the time
and when she talks
it's a sledgehammer on the nail and then
she goes back
to
to
chilling again watching observing
i know you know how hard it is raising a
daughter
i have five of them
five
don't make me come back over here again
there's a
a really unique uh strength that anjunu
was able to to capture there's like a
foundational power that just gets set in
the scene
that
everything and everyone else springs off
of it's a it's a it's a beautiful thing
uh to watch and uh
anjanu is a magnificent dance partner
well as we know the making of a scene
like that
part of it is the the acting and the
brilliance of it but but a big part of
it is how a scene is actually
constructed so i wanted to go
to you pamela to ask you how you put a
scene like this together you know i
approach it like any emotional scene
which is
um kind of
giving honor to everybody's
points of view or experience within the
scene i can see from
what miss orisen is going through right
from the beginning when they walk in the
door
that she's pissed and she's also
sort of resigned like this is something
that maybe she's lived before or just
understands well from her life
experience you've got the fear
and the upset of these young girls and
then obviously there's
uh you know what richard is going
through and his his anger
at the end of the day like we felt like
we could get that arc of the anger
bubbling up to kind of the explosion of
not only why he's pairing the team the
way he is but i i love how he throws in
that little zinger at the end of all
these events they've been going to and
the bad behavior he's seen from other
people's children and other people's
parenting and so you know you're putting
it together and you have to get all of
these moments for them all to click and
and
sort of get that full experience and i
think by going around the room in that
way you really see that i wanted to ask
chris about the score because in those
moments of silence we are we're hearing
the kind of emotional soundtrack at the
back and it's placing us in richard's
head orsin's head in the head of these
children these young girls chris how do
you go about
thinking about a scene like this
personally my process
really stems a lot from
my background as a jazz pianist where
i'm first and foremost an accompanist
right and like usually what i do is i
watch through a scene
without any music and just watch it to
see how it makes me feel you're seeing
this anger from richard in this moment
but also at the same time his his eyes
are welling up with with tears and
emotion and and seeing that emotion from
richard seeing the emotion from these
girls you know uh even like um like
seeing some of them cry and then also or
seen later those are the things that
naturally i'm feeling just watching it
and so then i usually go to the piano
and try to find something that can make
me feel that way or feel some of those
emotions by the time we worked on the
scene i already had richard's theme so i
was able to to use his theme it's really
subtle but the the string line you're
hearing is actually his theme really
stretched out and slowed down and
created you know a different harmony
there and the first iteration of it
actually did do a little bit too much i
mean it was still trying to keep it as
subtle as possible but
i remember the first version of it ray
and pam were like i think we can
simplify even more we can like take you
know even more out with a scene like
this it really is just following what's
happening and trying to make sure that
i'm supporting it as best as possible
well the words that richard says at the
scene where he's talking about and
really laying out in many ways
what drives him as a parent can you
speak to in that moment what richard is
thinking and what it says about how he
saw himself as a father
richard had a very specific
dream
and vision
um
that
miss orsine agreed
with
96
you know it demanded a certain
uh means you know it demanded a uh a
certain type of
hard work and attention uh but at the
center of it was
love and that was the thing that they
were betting on
and the world is telling them oh you you
you're pushing them
too
hard that you're you know your your
behavior is crazy and they're looking at
the insanity of this world and the
hypocrisy of it and the you know the the
the how dare you
is
part of the center
of this scene you the same jokers
that'll be shooting them down
in the streets like how dare you
you know this scene really captured that
that aspect beautifully
is this something that really happened
oh yes absolutely when
so much of this film takes place in this
family's home and in the world that they
occupied
can you talk to me about how you
constructed this world
and then secondarily how you constructed
this home where all these intimate
moments were going to take place
so many of the choices that i made
had an impact on the scene
if you look at the size of the house for
example the size of the house the
interior of the house is very very small
which means that once you get all these
people in there
it's like they can't they're like trying
to negotiate the space and because they
can't negotiate the space
it helps with the creation of the
tension in this particular scene
when horacing crosses that street
the audience goes oh they you know they
all get very excited about what's about
to happen
and if the block had been too large
that tension would not have been there
and then the other thing that we're
doing is that we're really providing the
viewer
with a sense of who these people are and
how they lived but not only are we doing
that for the viewer we're also doing
that for the actors
because the actors come into that home
and they have to live there well as a
designer i make sure that i fill up all
the spaces
which i hope are character details or
informing the actors
who their characters are
in many ways i think this scene
captures
a lot of the themes
of the movie
about the
difficulty facing richard and orcin in
raising these girls about the criticism
they were receiving again not just from
the white tennis parents
but even from some people
in their neighborhood in their world
what is the story that king richard
tells us
about black families
um and about the story of venus and
serena once you know you want to go
i'll go right quick
well first i mean i listening to these
other artists on this panel miss martin
and mr thomas
and mr bowers i want to say thank you
because you made my job much easier
so i really really appreciate that and
you know i just think so much i'm glad
that will brought up this question of
you know people coming from the south
and going north which is what my family
did leaving mississippi and going to
chicago and milwaukee and detroit
it promised that you could once again
like or or have some semblance
of of control
over your life some design over your
destiny and so when you are a family
like the williams family own their own
homes
went to work every day did all the right
things and here comes some part some
element in the world that will cut you
off at the shins i just feel it's just
one of these moments in this film that's
larger that that's not large that's
larger than the williams family and i
think that the reason that i say that is
because i know the response i get from
other families who watch this movie over
thanksgiving weekend
and felt reflected by it
and i say this all the time that you
know i don't the williams family are in
are extraordinary but they're not rare
what's rare is our our chance to see
that yeah and look i i you know gotta
gotta give a big shout out to zach
baylin who wrote this script and and
he gave us an incredible you know
blueprint um you know and an insight and
window into the williams life and then
to be magnified in this particular
moment you know that's a big big tip tip
of a cap to zach i think this particular
scene when you talk about themes and you
think about this family and all that
they have to overcome it's look they're
raising champions right we already know
that venus and serena have gotten to the
level that they are but we don't we
don't understand how they got there um
but they did it with this love and
commitment and what i love so much about
what will and injunu and the girls do in
the scene
is that it doesn't it doesn't lose uh
it's not angry black woman growing
across the street and there's a fine
line right there's a fine line between
being angry and she really is she's
pissed
but she's so poised she's so um
she's so composed and i think the
williams raised their girls
in a way that never allowed their
emotions to get the best of them they
were going places that no one else was
willing or or able to go and and it's
because of how they were raised it was
because of
moments like this
and how they conducted themselves within
these moments and within these spaces
but yeah the performances and and
everything that that you see before you
is a testament to uh to this family and
and how they inspired us to help tell
their story so thank you to the williams
family as well what a powerful
conversation thank you guys so much for
joining us again i'm wesley lowry um and
i'm so glad we're able to talk about
that powerful scene from the movie king
richard
thank you all thank you thank you thank
you